[Music]
so check out the new fad for the men of
Avengers endgame belting out a Beatles
classic during a photo shoot in LA and I
just want you to look at Chris Hemsworth
he just posed because you know what when
you look like that you can do anything
you want to do now as many of you know
this is the final Avengers movie the
last time this group will all be
together so the stars earned taking
their time savoring it and making the
most of it the end may be coming for the
Avengers but after 11 years and 22
movies this cast is bonded for infinity
at least the main the the og sex
what is the og 600 chain like No oh my
god it's so I have to actually take
myself off of it time and again for
Scarlett we owe this to everyone who's
not in this room to try alright what did
you take from Santa at the very end that
last day would you take Stone rekha you
did whoa you got the shield did you get
the suit no I haven't asked it for the
suit I'll get to argue
I'll get you can't get the sound get
this Hemi get those he did yeah did you
get your whole suit away my stretchy
pants yeah avengers endgame is the final
chapter in this superhero saga but just
like every other barble movie it's
shrouded in total secrecy what are you
talking about sure there's not a secret
you want to tell me last chance so I was
like what is it what is it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]